hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on Borderlands 3 again
and today we have another legendary
weapon showcase this one is gonna be the
sub lime storm or I'm pretty sure just
called the storm now it is a mallow one
legendary sniper rifle with a little bit
of a nice little quirk to it and some
nice little flavor text as always like
the V if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new and let's get started so
right off the bat going off the stats
this is a level 50 sniper rifle that I
have it is called the sub lime storm the
damage is 819 it has 92% accuracy at 55%
handling a 3 second reload speed can
shoot about one bullet per second and it
has a magazine size of 6 and the one
that I grabbed has shock damage which is
about a hundred and fifty nine damage
per second which is pretty solid now I'm
not actually sure if this is a multiple
element weapon just judging from the way
that this weapon works which I'll show
in a bit it might seem like it's only a
shock weapon which I'm totally not
against it I think it's pretty cool and
that 40% chance is pretty solid too
that's like one every two shots but
seeing as I'm playing amara and I
basically have this deadly elemental
build that that thing is gonna be
propping almost all the time anyway for
the other bits of information has a 20%
weapon charge speed a 15% reload speed
at 250 Splash Damage radius consumes 2
ml per shot so you're really gonna be
shooting only three and then a seven
point seven times weapon zoom the red
flavor text says tut tut it looks like
rain this is a reference to the movie
Winnie the Pooh in the honey tree from
1966 basically Winnie the Pooh wanted to
get some honey from this honey tree but
there was a lot of bees guarding it as
they usually do and he didn't want to be
stung by them so he basically covered
himself in this paint or this ink and
whatnot to make him this little black
rain cloud and while he was flying up he
was still getting stung so basically he
said I think it would help with this
deception if you would kind of just open
up your umbrella Robin and say tut tut
it looks like rain and then he proceeded
to do that and Pooh got his honey really
a nice throwback to a 1960s classic
that's pretty incredible but the weapon
itself is really damn good now as you'll
see this is a mallow on weapon so of
course it has that weapon charged up
speed at what you're going to be doing
is aiming at an opponent shooting that
bullet right at them and then a couple
of these little orbs I think it could be
from anywhere from two three or four I
think the numbers for I could be wrong
in that one but you'll see in the
gameplay what they
do is they surround the area where you
shot and then shock anything in its path
and thing that I noticed actually
throughout the recording that I was
doing is that you don't actually have to
admit you don't even actually have to
shoot them you can totally miss this
weapon like hit the wall next to them
and it'll still work so even if there's
somebody behind cover you can shoot the
cover in front of them and the orbital
still shock them from the behind which
is really cool this kind of reminds me
of the Khazar grenade I believe it's
either the Khazar or the storm thrown
from Borderlands 2 I know both those
grenades have made their return in
Borderlands 3 with some small
differences but one of the two you'll
have to remind me in the comments below
is actually kind of just like this
you'll throw the grenade down it creates
a little orb and then it's just start
shocking anything in its path I believe
it's the Khazar grenade I'm not the
storm front but once again I could be
totally wrong I've always got those
grenades mixed up in the past as you can
see just doing in terms of shield damage
this thing melts anything within seconds
of a shield obviously my stuff is a
little bit broken in the sense that I
have a huge elemental build with Amara
because that's what I felt that would
work with her and you know I carry every
single element with me that I need like
fire corrosion and shock and obviously
the fire weapon that I have completely
tears through health so it is a little
bit inflated on the damage but you might
as well just look at the shield values
they're absolutely wrecking anything
shield in its path yeah but the way the
weapon works is all you have to do is
either aim down this site or not aim at
all completely your choice and then you
look at the opponent or look at a wall
or something like that whatever you want
to shoot at hold it shoot it down just
like any mellow one weapon and then
three to four orbs will come up on at
the sky and start shocking anything in
its path it's pretty damn nice and like
I said you can use this behind cover
it's a super deadly weapon I would
definitely recommend this with anybody
who has trouble with dealing anything
with shock maybe you're trying to farm a
boss that has a shield and you want to
inch that stuff down as quick as
possible but it's totally cool if you
are using Amara I would definitely
recommend this if you don't have a shock
- there's probably loads of better shock
weapons I mean I have a shock pistol
right now that's doing pretty solid and
it's obviously shooting a lot faster and
downing the shield a lot quicker than
the sniper rifle because of that charge
rate but if you don't have anything I
feel like and also if you want to shoot
from a distance I feel like the sniper
rifle is a pretty good choice to have in
your elemental builds yeah and then
lastly of course is where I got the
weapon just in case you want to know
this I really didn't get this from
anywhere specifically it's just world
drop loot you
when anybody ever says world drop or
random drop loot they mean the legendary
ting farm which of course has since been
patched or they're basically just
farming grave ward so obviously if you
just want to get a legendary loot just
any any type of legendary loot you can
definitely do that as well I didn't get
this from anybody specifically sadly the
only person that I was really farming at
the time I believe was Tron so just in
case if you didn't get the weapon from
any role drop I would maybe check trompe
but I'm fairly certain I didn't drop
that from him because I used it on him
when I was recording another gameplay
it's really about it let me know what
you guys think about this weapon in the
comments below if it'll fit with your
build if you think it's a solid weapon
regardless I just like the light let me
know in the comments below
personally for me I'm not really a big
fan of Malinois weapons although I do
have a couple in my inventory that I use
all the time melih want weapons or they
bother the [ __ ] out of me because of
this really large charge time I don't
know why they happened to change that in
Borderlands 3 Borderlands 2 malla Wan
was completely fine they just kind of
had to [ __ ] it up with this charge rate
yeah but that guy's like to be if you do
enjoy subscribe if you're new and take
care guys have a very austere day and
peace out
[Music]
[Music]
you